good morning everyone welcome to the
first episode of
wepa in the morning my name is giannis
pappas
and i'm christian stefano damie mosca
solina
vomit yes this we're to do a morning
show every day
based off giannis's morning show that he
did on
what was it [ __ ] fusion papa fritas
what was it what was the [ __ ]
spanish network that you did that they
sung 10 billion dollars into and then it
just failed
uh
we're gonna do here every day we just
rolled out of bed i got out of bed three
minutes ago janice is still in bed so
what we're going to do
is i have my ruler like i said yesterday
i'm going to measure my morning wood to
see if corona got in our penises
so take a peek and i guess those are
just
those are your history how you need
glasses now cuz
three and a half inches three and a half
inches
yeah okay i'm going to take my ruler and
take a message we're going to do a
little morning here
wet by in the morning a little magic
everyone's got to do it at home
it's not a crota club i have allergies
i am an inch and a half right now wow
your dick's like a thumb um there's a
lot in the news going on that we want to
talk about
um thanks for showing up we hope you
have your morning coffee
we hope that you got your newspaper out
you're eating your croissant
you're eating your bagel you know uh
mike is eating his frosted flakes
whatever you do for breakfast um okay
whatever it is you're american we're not
here to judge
is vaping vanity is vaping chris johnson
the prime minister of
england is in the hospital with corona
with the coco
with the crown and he said he's uh he's
on oxygen in the icu but the thing is is
i don't believe it could also just be
political i mean
a lot of these political leaders and
actors and actors will just say they
have corona or get it
for the story on their balls and then
when you're done they just go like this
this is the first morning show where a
host has smelt his own balls that just
made history it's just what it is that's
a surefire way to wake yourself up it's
like smelling salt from your nuts
so do you think so boris johns do you
think he's gonna get out of the hospital
yes or no
yeah i don't believe in the conspiracy
theories i don't see what
anyone benefits from it i you know i
believe and there's too many people
who would know that boris johnson is
making it up i mean the guy's going to
hospitals i don't see what the public no
no
no no i'm not i'm not saying he's making
up i guarantee you he has it for sure
but i'm saying to go to the icu do you
think that's for
like morale like do you think like he's
going to beat it like like uh
like you know we can beat this we can do
this the british love to do that they
love to say
you know winston churchill though he's
like we're fighting together
yeah man i mean all the news is just
about the coronavirus now they're saying
that the uh
uh the us comfort the usns comforts
capacity cut in half to treat
coronavirus patients like you got to get
the coronavirus patients on the boat
and just get the boat the hell out of
new york harbor i mean is that can we
just do that can we load them up and get
that boat the [ __ ] out of here
they need to ban wet markets the problem
is i think china has already
outlawed the wet markets i believe the
wet markets are black market that's the
problem because
here's the thing about the united
nations it's a great idea i support it i
hope it works one day
but they're sort of like a referee in a
professional wrestling match
they don't really do [ __ ] like nobody
listens nobody listens people just keep
eating each other with chairs
and they're yelling and nobody respects
them physically because i think that's
the only way
to really get rid of them is if you just
take the physically let's get frank
rizzo out from his [ __ ] grave
and let have him start taking the
chinese physically what's up everybody
welcome to wepa in the morning
it's almost friday but that doesn't mean
anything to anybody cause
everyone's quarantined what's up good
morning
good morning i'm an ff i forgot to put
on my background
no mistake cause we're pregnant i can't
help it
cause listen when britney goes to
motherhood maternity you're gonna go
with her and you're going to get
yourself a moomo
i'm good i'm going to do that in
solidarity with her because
we're pregnant we're eating donuts
we're having weird cravings so i mean
[ __ ] donald trump's going wild and
saying
we made the right decision by locking
down and elon musk's
is [ __ ] tweeting open up and he's go
he's saying california
hospitals are half empty and he's he's
gone liberate america he's
tweeting all the things that are gonna
get crazy people with ar-15s in the
street in a second
because everyone is losing their mind
it's complete chaos it's actually kind
of scary
the only normalcy we have right now is
wepa in the morning
weapon in the morning it's the only
normalcy we got i mean yeah
at some point let's just i mean the
country it's really just when they say
the country i mean they really just mean
new york city right i mean it's just
like
let's be honest here there's really no
corona problem other than in new york
so why don't we just [ __ ] start
talking about let's build a wall around
new york city let's protect
us and then everybody else get back to
doing what you're doing because nobody
else really even cares
this chemical chinese chemical bio
weapon they sent it right to new york i
know iowa wants to feel important but
nobody
gives a [ __ ] okay i would shut the [ __ ]
up and take your shirt off and open back
up
it's donald trump's nemesis yeah donald
trump's name assistant
yeah rosie o'donnell
i mean
it might be shawnee d who sean donnelly
shaved his face yesterday it looked
yeah it's a little short donnelly i mean
cuz i mean her hair's [ __ ] wild
i mean you know i mean so would you what
do you think fermate no fermate
more but see this is what it is this is
in this you know pre-pandemic in the
pre-pandemic world celebrities ditch it
like this now the post pandemic it's
like people like yes celebrity
i don't care they're like shut up if
you're not doing anything real shut up
shut up shut up
yeah go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild
[Music]